the magnanimous Arthur with all the
kings and military force of Britain
fought against the Saxons and though
there were many more noble than himself
yet he was twelve times chosen their
commander and was as often Conqueror
this is a quote from the ancient texts
known as historia Britain on which was
one of the oldest records of King
Arthur's life story we've all grown up
watching movies and reading books about
the legend of King Arthur
a young man pulls the magic sword
Excalibur from the stone and a wizard
named Merlin guides him into manhood as
an adults he established the legendary
knights of the round table and ruled
over Camelot future generations would
look to him as the first king of the
British Empire
however while everyone knows him by name
few people know the whole story behind
the man who became the legends here on
by graphics today we aim to uncover the
truth behind King Arthur of Camelot
[Music]
during the 5th century the modern-day
united kingdom was called Britannia the
Roman conquerors had been driven out of
the lands and the ancient Britons they
were left to govern themselves without a
central government the country
it was plunged into a time known as the
Dark Ages
several Celtic tribal leaders declared
themselves of the king but there was
never one ruler who governed them all if
this reminds you a little bit of Game of
Thrones that's because george RR martin
got a lot of his inspiration from these
ancient stories of early middle age war
and conquest as you might imagine many
of these kingdoms within the British
Isles they were at war with one another
and this made it impossible for anyone
to settle down and establish any new art
or culture there's a lot of mystery
surrounding that time because very few
people were bothering to keep a historic
record of daily life almost everyone was
illiterate from the peasants all the way
up to the nobility Christian clergymen
were the only ones who knew how to read
and write but they often isolated
themselves from the rest of society in
favor of devoting their lives to
theological study without a central
economy citizens of Patania did not have
money in the form of coins or bills so
rather people were using a barter system
to trade goods and services most
peasants were farmers and they grew
enough food to feed themselves but even
within this barter system people were
still expected to pay taxes to their
feudal lords in the form of goods and
labor oftentimes if two kings were
fighting over control of the land
peasants had to pay taxes twice in one
year also without a proper education
system people believed in magic and were
incredibly superstitious while
Christianity existed many were still
practicing the ancient pagan traditions
it was during this unstable time when
Arthur was born without any written
records we don't know the exact date of
his birth but we do know that he was
conceived in tinta goal which is on the
coast of Cornwall in 2016 an
archaeological dig at tentacle revealed
that the city held many of the lavish
luxury imported goods along the coast of
Cornwall at the time it would have been
a town bustling with activity as boats
sailed in and out of the harbour
Arthur's father was a man named King
Uther Pendragon he lusted after a
beautiful woman named lady Igraine but
she was married to his rival Lord
Gauloise according to legends Pendragon
asked his in-house whiz
Merlin to cast a magic spell he wanted
to look like Gorlois
so that he could trick a grain into
having sex with him of course
modern historians believe that Merlin
was not a wizard at all that actually
one of the last remaining Celtic druids
at the time druids were thought to have
magical powers and a connection to the
spiritual world
the Druids lived their lives being one
with nature and practicing herbal
medicine they were known to be
incredibly wise and were some of the
most intelligent people of the time King
Pendragon waited until Lord Gauloise
left on a business trip and then he
appeared before lady Igraine disguised
as a husband considering that we know
that magic isn't real we know that
Merlin could not have cast a spell to
cloak his appearance it is far more
likely that Uther Pendragon took a
hirable potion from Merlin in order to
help him violate her later Lord called
why I was horrified to learn that his
wife had been raped by an impostor she
ultimately became pregnant with pen
dragons baby this illegitimate child was
the boy known as Arthur lady Igraine did
not want to raise the baby and no one
wanted to claim responsibility
Merlin felt incredibly guilty for his
part in all of this and knew that the
boy was actually a prince he took pity
on Arthur and chose to raise him as his
own son Lord gall Warren's lady Igraine
would go on to have their own daughter
and that would be Arthur's half sister
Morgan
[Music]
the Druids were not the only ones who
were thought to be magical in most
cultures around the world women who
lived alone were often accused of
practicing witchcraft a young woman
named Vivian was known as the Lady of
the lake but instead of being a
frightening old witch she was described
as a beautiful fairy who lived
underwater now we know that she wasn't a
fairy of course and that she was just a
woman living alone in a cottage near a
lake for years the lands they were
filled with watery lakes and marshes
Christian clergymen built their
monasteries on small islands and the
only way that people could travel there
was by boat or by walking on long
causeways that were built over the water
in the 1700s this land was drained of
water to utilize the farmlands but it
wasn't until recently that modern
archaeological digs uncovered a huge
amount of Iron Age swords axes shields
armor and tools that had been thrown
into the water ancient Britons had a
tradition of making an offering to the
Lord of the land's by tossing their
weapons into the lakes and marshes
because of a reputation as a magical
fairy Vivian's Lake was also a spot
where people would throw their swords
and weapons in exchange for her blessing
one day the vien discovered that someone
had left a very different kind of
offering on her doorstep it was a
newborn baby boy who had been abandoned
by his mother she decided to raise the
orphan child as her own and named him
Lancelot Merlin was wise enough to know
that the Lady of the lake wasn't a fairy
at all and he was entranced by Vivian's
beauty and strength he fell in love with
her and pleaded for her to give him a
chance Vivian said that she would
consider Merlin's proposal if he taught
her everything he knew in the more
mystical versions of the story Merlin
toward Vivian how to practice magic but
you know it's more likely that he was
actually showing her how to become a
druid in the end they say that the Lady
of the lake traps Merlin forever of
course we know that if she's trapped
anything it was his heart they fell in
love and lived together in that cottage
on the lake since Vivian was raising
Lancelot and Merlin adopted Arthur the
two boys would have grown up together as
brothers
[Music]
you've all heard the epic tale of how
young Arthur was able to pull the sword
Excalibur out of the stone and people
dropped to their knees
this ended all of their ongoing battles
in order to recognize him as their one
true king unfortunately we now know that
this version of the story is total
fantasy the warring kingdoms they
continued to fight one another for
control of the land during Arthur's
youth Lancelot and Arthur they practiced
dueling one another from an early age
Arthur's sword was called many names
including Caliburn and Excalibur other
versions of the story leave out the
stone completely and say that the Lady
of the lake gave Excalibur to Arthur
according to a researcher from the
University of Wales Rachel Bromwich the
name Excalibur may have similarly arisen
at a very early date as a generic name
for a sword after all Vivian had an
endless supply of weapons that were
thrown into our lake since everyone
bartered for supplies during the Dark
Ages it would only make sense that
Viviane would dive into the lake to
retrieve as many valuable weapons as she
could Arthur and Lancelot have the rare
luxury of practicing with these
expensive swords from an early age and
they were already skilled fighters years
before they became Knights when she was
a teenager bartha's half-sister morgan
wanted to become a druid as well so she
began to study under Merlin she and the
nickname Morgan la Fey or Morgan Ferry
that this time offer had no idea that
Morgan was actually his half-sister the
two teenagers they felt deeply in love
Merlin forbid the two of them from being
together of course but he never revealed
the secrets that they were actually
siblings but just like any rebellious
teenagers in love trying to keep them
apart only made their passion grow
stronger
Merlin realized that he needed to reveal
the truth before it was too late
[Music]
by the time he was in his late teens
Arthur became one of the most skilled
warriors in the land and he gained a
massive amount of respect from other
Knights King Pendragon and his wife they
never had another male heir to the
throne
Merlin finally revealed the truth to
Arthur that he was actually the prince
and the true successor to the crown but
this family drama it had to be put on
the back burner because the Saxons began
to invade Britannia the Saxons were the
ancient German people and they couldn't
help but notice all of the chaos going
on over in England they thought that
because the Roman Empire was gone maybe
this was their chance to take over the
land for themselves according to a ninth
century writer Nennius then in those
days Arthur fought against the Saxons
with the king of the Britons but he was
commander in those battles Nennius goes
on to list 12 different battles across
all of Britannia where Arthur was said
to have fought and conquered the
invaders this would have taken years of
dedication moving from place to place
until all of the Saxons were driven out
of the British Isles soon enough
Arthur's name it spread across the lands
after gaining a loyal fan base
Arthur revealed that he was the
illegitimate son of King Pendragon the
people of all these Celtic kingdoms
chose to bend the knee to Arthur rent he
was crowned as the once and future king
laughter built his own castle in
Camelot's which is said to be located in
modern-day Wales after becoming King
everyone now knew who Arthur's parents
were and he could never marry his
half-sister Morgan so he therefore
married a woman called Lady Guinevere
instead she became its Queen it is said
that she was one of the most beautiful
women in the lands of us like many royal
marriages theirs was one of Duty rather
than love Morgan got married to a man
called King lot of Orkney ruler of
Norway so she became queen and went on
to have a son named Gawain despite the
fact that they now knew they were
siblings Arthur and Morgan was still in
love with one another they could not
contain their passion and continued this
forbidden romance behind closed doors
she became pregnant and gave birth to
their son Mordred once lots had fought
alongside Arthur during the war and he
was celebrated as being one of the most
skilled Knights in the land he continued
to stay by Arthur's side as a lord in
Arthur's Court and married a beautiful
young woman named Lady Elaine Lancelot
would participate in dowsing tournaments
and became an undefeated champion Queen
Guinevere could sense that King Arthur
was not loyal to her so she and Lancelot
began having a secret love affair
together during his battles against the
Saxons Arthur gathered his knights that
he knew he could trust
he built a large round table in the
Great Hall of his castle he chose this
circular shape so that no man would be
in a seat that was more important than
the others dozens of men would gather to
discuss politics and plan for future
quests Arthur and his knights they went
on countless adventures together one of
the most famous quests was the search
for the Holy Grail which was said to
have been the cup that Jesus Christ
drank from during the Last Supper
according to the 12th century writer
shret Aeon to Troy that Grail was made
of the finest pure gold and in it was
that precious stones of many kinds the
richest and most precious in the earth
or the sea legend has it that wandering
from this calf would heal all wounds and
guarantee that its owner would be
granted eternal life many historians
believe that the legend of the Holy
Grail was simply putting a Christian
twist on the pagan myth of the cauldrons
of Plenty but that did not stop these
men from attempting to find this
mythical item Lancelot and Lady Elaine
they went on to have a son named Galahad
who was said to have one of the purest
hearts of all the Knights in Britannia
as the story goes Galahad was the only
knight who had a true enough heart to
touch the Grail but he died attempting
find it most scholars believe that the
Holy Grail is just a myth while others
say that it is a real artifact waiting
to be discovered
so anyway Morgan la Fey found out about
Lancelot and Guinevere love affair and
she revealed the truth to Arthur despite
the fact that everyone was cheating on
one another this revelation it's still
outraged Arthur and he felt completely
betrayed by his best friends Arthur's
knights they stormed Lancelot's chamber
and he was tortured and killed Queen
Guinevere was allowed to live but she
had to witness her true love died as a
result of the affair Arthur's son and
also nephew Mordred knew from an early
age that he was a child of incest but he
would never be able to reveal the truth
to the public that he was the true out
of the throne when he grew up
Mordred was knighted but he had to
pretend to be only his father's nephew
Modred's older brother Gawain ascended
to the throne of Norway but was also a
loyal member of King Arthur's round
table like many roles who were the
product of incest Mordred was known for
being a little bit more than crazy he
has an incredibly violent temper during
battle Queen Guinevere and Arthur never
had any children together so that was
never an heir to the throne of Camelot
Mordred grew up hating his father and he
came up with a plan for how to take the
throne for himself heartbroken over the
loss of her beloved Lancelot Queen
Guinevere spent most of her days alone
in the castle one day King Arthur was
away on one of his many quests Mordred
saw this is an opportunity to seduce
Guinevere and it worked the Queen saw
this is a second chance of happiness so
she ran off to marry this young man who
she thought was her husband's nephew in
this case all we could say is good that
there at least not blood relatives
anyway in his father's absence Modred's
sat on Arthur's throne and declared to
everyone in the kingdom that he was now
the new king of Camelot when Arthur
returned home he saw Mordred had taken
the throne this betrayal is what sparked
the Battle of Camlann where father and
son fought one another in the
battlefield they were both mortally
wounded killing one another when Arthur
died his body was taken to an island
called Avalon to be buried
now just before we get into the legacy I
do want to point out that the day this
video when live is indeed April the 1st
of 2019 King Arthur was not a real
person happy April Fool's Day we sorry
to say but the character of King Arthur
was a complete work of fiction and so
was this entire video
the legends we now know today came from
a British historian called Geoffrey of
Monmouth who wrote the 11th century book
called the history of the kings of
Britain according to archaeologist dr.
Myles Russell the legend of King Arthur
is really based on five different
individual leaders in the ancient world
the first was called Ambrosius orally
honest and he was actually one of the
people who defeated the Saxons in battle
there were also elements of the true
stories of Roman rulers like constantine
the great and magnus maximus dr. russell
says Arthur's birth marriage midlife
crisis and dramatic death these are
elements that have already happened when
you take them away from Arthur's story
there is nothing left for Arthur the
character Geoffrey gives us is an echo
of other people I suspect he's trying to
create a Celtic superhero the legend of
King Arthur became even more elaborate
during the 12th century when a French
poet named Troy added all of the
romantic elements to the story he is the
one who handed the details about Merlin
the lady in the lake and the romance
between lady Guinevere and Lancelot
despite the fact that these texts were
not historically accurate the fact that
they contains half truths and half
fictions was enough to confuse future
generations kings and queens and Britain
spent over a thousand years believing
that King Arthur was real they saw this
as the original establishment of the
British Empire even King Henry the
seventh named his firstborn son Prince
Arthur and declared that he would bring
on a new Arthurian age he set about to
legitimize the legends and declared that
the stories were true historic facts
even commissioned a roundtable to be
built in his own castle so that he could
live like the legendary King the
tradition to honor King Arthur continued
well into the 1800s where Queen Victoria
commissioned an entire wall of the
roaming room of the Parliament building
to show the story of King Arthur's life
and his rise to power even well into the
20th century the Nazis believed that
they needed to avenge their saxon
ancestors and the nazis tula society set
out on their
own quest for the Holy Grail in the
1930s it wasn't until very recently that
archeologists and historians of
questions the existence of King Arthur
as of chosen to write off the story it's
just a legend despite the fact that it's
a way of pure fiction King Arthur
continues to capture the imagination of
people around the world and will
continue to do so for years to come so
now there's no in the comment section if
you were fooled by this video or if
you're just a bit too clever to fall for
it maybe for watching this on April
Fool's Day could be a good thing to send
to friends or family and as always thank
you for watching
[Music]